every single one of you by voting
conscience that's how you change things
you change things by voting for who you
believe in this is a celebration I think
it is just the start of a really big
movement the libertarian movement I
don't feel like the fact that we voted
for Gary caused that to happen it was
not a vote for Trump it was a vote for
the right thing it was not a protest we
were rooting for the right guy I have
friends who are on both sides of the
pole my Republican friends tell me hey
vote for Johnson is a vote for Hillary
my Democratic friends tell me hey I vote
for Johnson is a vote for Trump into
what would what I say to them is a vote
for Johnson is a vote for change it's a
vote to put a third party on the map the
day after the elections is gonna be a
big hangover for America and a lot of
people are gonna look at us libertarians
and say you caused this your votes
you threw away your vote and I'm gonna
say back to them no because I can look
back 20 years from now and say I voted
for the Libertarian Party because of
what I believe in and what I've stood up
to those people who voted for Trump are
responsible for a trump presidency so I
think that in the primaries that was
where that decision was made and I think
the libertarians have their own voice
and they speak for themself and so I
think the results that we're seeing
tonight is basically the results of a
very very flawed system a very flawed
debating system to that as far as the
presidential debates go and so I think
that these deficits have to be accounted
for somehow there's a phrase that I like
to hear any gambler likes to hear it
it's called covering the spread and if
you look up on that map that they're
showing on TV you'll see a lot of states
where Gary Johnson covered the spread
and there's gonna be a lot of Old Party
politicians whining and crying tomorrow
about all the votes they should've had
well you know what I say to that your
tears are delicious and your parties
will die
if you want our votes if you want to win
in America then you have to deal with
the issues of the racist war on drugs
you have to deal with the issue of our
twenty trillion dollar national debt you
have to deal with the country that no
longer wants to send its sons and
daughters overseas to die in other
countries civil wars and if you don't
deal with those issues and if you don't
address libertarian issues then you will
lose get used to it do you regret your
vote knowing what the outcome is no no
because I don't think I don't think us
voting for Hillary would have been any
better we voted for the candidate that
deserved to win we voted for the man
that should have been our president two
days from now who did you vote for two
months from now who did you vote for
two years twenty years always hold your
head high all of you
you absolutely Rock thank you very very
very much for being out here and
supporting this campaign